all right guys
bang bang kendrick is back
for i think round two maybe round three
but i think round two
uh thanks so much for uh for doing this
man thank you so much for having me palm
uh
such an honor and always a pleasure
absolutely so for those that didn't
listen to the first one we did together
maybe just let's start with kind of 60
seconds on your background
and kind of the things you did to get to
a republic and start that business
uh yes sir i started out as a securities
lawyer i was a introduced general
counsel
i and launched republic about four years
ago
at first nothing to do with blockchain
in 2017 helped uh
introduced to co-found coin list
uh set that up uh and coinless is a
phenomenal team
they didn't need me anymore so i went
back to uh to republic
uh but uh we basically a investment
platform one of the largest by now
seven hundred thousand community members
uh and investing in
uh from seed stage all the way to like
free ipo
some of the projects uh crypto projects
um
but you know most of our deals still are
in traditional equity
got it and so one of the things that's
really interesting i think about what
you guys have done
is uh and you really gave me kind of a
crash course on
um these regulation a plus type
offerings versus
other types of offerings and so maybe
give us a quick update just
what has gone on at republic for the
last kind of two years or so
how much of that is through reg a plus
versus maybe other types of
regulations where the fundraising is
occurring uh i'll start
with an offering that we have right now
is a combination
of right d and reggae which is our own
token called the republic note token but
why don't we just i give a very quick
overview of all of these regulations uh
in a way that is you know
uh for mainstream consumption so they're
really
only three ways for which non-accredited
investor in the us
can acquire private securities or
additional securities
either the company has gone ipo gone
public
and that's a really high hurdle
obviously very few opt for that route
there's a regulation cf stand for crowd
funding
very easy couple thousand dollars any
project or company
after two three weeks uh can go through
a platform right like republican race
but there's a cap a million dollars
right now soon to be five million
meaning you cannot take more than a
million dollars from non-accredited
investors
then there's reggae which is between rex
cf and going public
costs about a couple hundred thousand
dollars probably about six months to
prepare for
and then either a company or a project
like republic or
block staff or props can raise up to
50 million dollars from non-accredited
investors
and the i i see non-accredited investor
loosely but it essentially means anyone
and everyone you can be a student you
can be a
you know bill gate and you can invest
openly
into the the campaign so
how is relevant to uh digital securities
or token offerings in the us
is that i do very much believe that the
the challenge the roadblock
for industry adoption up until now has
been
the lack of everyday folks participating
and there are a couple of reasons for
that one of which is that most people
are not accredited right in the u.s it's
like 95
of everyone are not accredited and so
they have not been able to
compliantly get in which is why you see
the industry more or less the same as it
was two
or three years ago got it and so when
you guys
work with uh companies that want to
raise funds
uh are they doing both or all three uh
reg cf
reg a plus uh and reg d or do you just
work on the reg d and reg a plus side
the
uh the different exemptions different
tools
got to be like case-by-case analysis on
how they come
to to apply and that's why the isn't
really
anytime soon like a sas model that hey
if you come to us
no human touch or advice is needed and
boom you launch
no because it depends on you know what
your customer
base you know look like and and how much
money you're looking to raise uh so
very few projects would do all three of
them
either you do reg d which is what any
company
and token offering in recent years uh
have been doing uh and you add on the
rex c
f or right a component for
non-accredited
and interestingly enough in the united
states today still they've only been two
rep a offerings for token offering as
far as i know
which is block staff and props and
republic is working on
the third one got it and so when people
are coming in to vet this what's the
type of information that they're getting
today
and then what does that look like in
terms of you mentioned 700 000
kind of people on the platform what does
that look like in terms of capital
raised so far
yeah if you go to republic today uh
there's you see
the public arm of republic which is
companies we have onboarded under either
right cf or right day
meaning anyone can see even a student
can invest as little as 10 or 20 dollars
now the the information that each
company posts
goes through outstanding process so they
kind of like the same there's a video
there's a little bit of like a few
bullet points on on highlights
and then there's a link to their
financials posted
on an ssc website which is very
different than deals done
privately we do have a private arm
deploying private capital under what is
known as wreck e
and that is similar to how the venture
ecosystem works
very opaque not a whole lot of
information only for
sophisticated investors that can look at
a company and make their own assessment
on whether or not
this is a deal worth doing and on that
side you only see a deal
once we're done with it unless you're
invited as part of the network
we've deployed capital into carter uh
spacex
relativity uh you know all of robinhood
most recently
so the the profile of the project is
very different
one leaning lady stage and the other one
is on the earlier stage
got it and maybe talk a little bit about
uh some of the projects themselves in
terms of uh
what those companies do your for those
that are just listening
uh you're sitting and you have a zoom
background and uh the two posters one of
them says investing crazy ideas
uh and the other says investing crazy
visionaries so maybe talk a little bit
about what what are some of those things
that
you've seen come through on the platform
and be successful yeah you know i
i want to share a fun fact and up until
recently i think our industry people
think of like blockchain as like
a standalone you know completely
bifurcated from the rest of the world
and i don't think so at all i think
blockchain is just a technology that's
like interwoven
with fintech uh you know necessarily so
so um the investment and the products
that we do
even on the surface seems to have
nothing to do
with crypto of blockchain down the road
uh we are working on tokenizing all of
them
and there will be d5 products uh you
know on the back of the investment that
you're seeing right now
but diving back into to your question
right now you know
there's a company called t-o-t-e-o-h
and it's essentially zoom 3-d right and
they while they were raising on republic
they also closed a
investment from spark capital which is a
you know a top tier vc
but technologies that people understand
uh because
you're talking about mainstream
presentation and people typically take
less than two minutes to look at the
deal page and make an investment
so it has to be technology that people
generally understand
so we see a lot of deals in that
framework and i think
snowball money is the deal that most
recently closed and as a blockchain
company
but in a way that's very relatable you
know work uh
obviously in in finance i think the
block stack
the the the traditional uh protocols
probably won't get mainstream adoption
just because uh it's harder to
understand and so the adoption will come
later
whereas i think d5 and and tokenized
securities
i think that will drive the industry
forward quickly
got it and then maybe talk a little bit
about um how much capital has been
raised on the platform or kind of what
the average deal size looked like so
people can understand that
yes uh again it's still a breaking down
between a public platform and a private
platform but in the aggregate we've done
over 150 million dollars
since inception much of that which is
over 125
came in the past 18 months right so it's
just a snowballing effect uh for for
what is a nascent
industry but this year we do hope to
close the year
over 200 million in in
total investment value that's awesome
congratulations on that
um there's a lot of people who say hey
digital securities
uh i've heard this narrative before
right i thought that this was going to
be a massive thing
in 2018 2019
it doesn't feel like it kind of
accomplished what i thought it was going
to accomplish not saying that it won't
in the future but just
it kind of didn't happen as fast as i
thought it would how do you
talk through that with investors or kind
of think about that
given that you kind of a front row seat
to this every day
is a great question tom and i have been
getting that question
uh you know a few times in in talking to
institutional investors
as we were looking to fundraise about
six months ago
and the answer is this if you have this
notion
of so-called additional securities
that change i mean 80 years of financial
uh ecosystem financial products wall
street
we're talking about making it possible
for
the masses to participate easily buy and
sale
bypassing the nasdaq you know the oc
otc destiny world naturally it would
take a little bit of time everyone
thought that like hey back in 2017
i certainly thought that by 2020 uh the
word of
finance would be much more decentralized
blockchain would have played
a a bigger role and i was wrong i was
definitely a little bit too early for a
number of reasons
one is that technically the the
functionalities the future sets that
would enable this
didn't quite exist back then that is how
do you conduct
know your customer anti-money laundering
how do you verify accreditation
how do you block jurisdiction uh
barriers
you have to do all of these things to be
in the good grades of the sec and finra
and all of these regulators
so when it comes to to digital
securities you do
have to account for government and
regulations
and that whole compliance framework the
technology did not have adequate
features
to make that possible a feasible now as
of like the end of last year and earlier
this year
everything is there even the the legal
and business framework we had it back
then
but no one has gone through it back in
2017
there had never been a reg a involving
digital securities the sec
finally slowly went through that process
so there were a few missing components
for the industry that
that necessarily prevented adoption uh
technically and legally
and then there hasn't been i think a
major
asset that people look at it
your your doctor who's retired now in
milwaukee
didn't know very much about blockchain
you can look at the asset
and say that huh i get it this is
relatable we haven't seen anything like
that we've seen
real estate properties you know some
like class b
property somewhere being tokenized and
available to accredited investors only
how can you have active trading active
market and adoption with that kind of
a nascent uh emotions that said
though now i do very much believe that
over the next 12 months
you're going to see a renaissance of
sort when it comes to sto and digital
securities
and so when you think about that uh what
what type of asset do you think
could be kind of the the breaking of the
dam
in demand like what type of asset would
that take
a little selfishly and self-promotional
but
i obviously think that the republic note
token um
which we we launched the public sale a
few days ago
and glad to share that uh the the soft
cap that we put was over subscribed
within just a couple of days
but we have a very large community and
our token i should
describe it a little bit is a
profit-sharing token
that is when a company on republic sees
an exit
we realize some proceeds and we pay that
proceeds out to the token holders
proportional to the token that they have
so if uh someone buys a republic token
and robinhood or spacex goes public in
two years
this is going to be a very small amount
but an amount
being paid out to to the token voters
that is relatable meaning people can
look at it and say
here's a regulated business with
clear revenue with over 150 million
dollars have been invested
and they have upside in these deals and
we have this community which is 700 000
and growing so we do think that the the
our user base alone is larger than many
exchanges
and so we have the ability to to imbibe
itself
feel that liquidity and demand but we
are just
you know basically the first of many to
come our goal is to identify
major movies sport league studios
real estate portfolio help them tokenize
and make it available to to the masses
um but yes i mean the the the use case
for tokenization
i think are just countless uh and uh the
concern is
once the floodgate has been open
and people see the value in it how can
the system
accommodate you know let's see all at
once
uh 20 different very large enterprises
wanting to tokenize but that's a good
problem to have
for sure and maybe explain a little bit
more about uh the republic note token
because i saw a couple of announcements
online but my understanding is an
investor can come in they buy the token
all of that money gets pulled together
uh it gets
invested into deals that go through the
republic platform
and then as uh there's profits it gets
distributed back
on a pro-rata basis to investors or am i
misunderstanding that
yes no no i there's no reinvestment in
this one sense uh
think of uh the easiest way of looking
at it is this if i may use an analogy
of you know back in 1996 if amazon
were to say that hey we're gonna issue
pre-minted
fix 800 million token and then we're
going to put
25 of our revenue from there on
whenever 25 revenue is generated they're
gonna make a distribution now to these
tokens
on an evergreen basis at the time
probably
was a modest uh distribution uh but
obviously fast forward 20 years each of
those tokens would be i don't
know how many hundreds of thousands of
dollars in value
the same concept here which is we
pre-made
a fixed pool of token and then on a
perpetual basis
we will make distribution of profit back
to the token holders
what are those profits we have an upside
we
every company that raises on republic we
have an upside potential
whenever a company sees an exit that
upside potential
is realizing cash that cash is paid back
through a stream an issuer and going
back to the token borders
so one way of another way of looking at
it is that
when we started out with this project
and where i think we were binance first
portfolio company
we had done only about 15
raises and we've raised less than six
million dollars
and even at the time finance was like
there's a potential for this
would the pool of future profit and
asset
over a year and a half two years now is
over 150 million
in total amount raised and the pool of
asset is probably worth at least
20 times what it was in 2018. so if we
continue for two more years it's just
increasingly amplifying an evergreen
basis
yeah that that's awesome and what's
really interesting about this
is uh the profit share uh
is basically the profit of all the
successful companies that go
through the republic platform right
because if they're unsuccessful there
will be no profits but
when they're they are successful it's a
way to kind of almost index your
exposure to to a bunch of different
companies it seems like
correct so the the the unusual attribute
of that
and you know you being one of the most
prolific and known veterinary
capitalists in the space as well as you
know generally speaking
we all know that if you just invest even
if you
were to just invest in one or two or
three deals and no more
i mean there's a high high risk of you
seeing very little of that money back
right
so the name of the game is obviously a
number game
even among the very best venture
capitalists
so what's unusual about the republic no
token is that it gives
note holders indirect exposure on an
evergreen basis meaning at one point
say 10 years down the road republic has
done 15 000 deals
through uh crowd capital that
every note holder as long as you hold a
note when a company
out of that pool exit you're gonna see a
payout
which lends itself to a very unusual
token economic
issue that is people will be reluctant
to sell because the moment that if i
hold a note token and i will sell it to
you
uh palm and all of a sudden robin hood
sees an exit
the payout will be to the new note
holder not me
so out of that that that psychology of
wanting to hold on for long-term return
rather than plum and dumb i do think
that it's going to introduce an
interesting but probably a positive
dynamics to to
token economics compared to what we have
seen in the past couple of years
yeah it's super interesting and i guess
how does this impact the traditional
markets right so we see like a coin base
for example
that's been talking about uh or at least
rumored to be talking about potentially
going public
uh i know that brian armstrong
previously had said that like the most
on brand thing would be to
digitize or tokenize the equity of the
business it sounds like maybe now
they're exploring the traditional side
at some point it feels like those two
markets like they meet
right and either they merge together and
play nicely or
one ends up winning and the other ends
up losing is it just kind of how do you
think about digital securities
versus traditional market over like a
very long period of time
i'm obviously gonna guess make big make
a
guess here on the decision uh making
process
at coinbase but i think at one point uh
the management team at coinbase made the
decision
that hey we're so large now with an
institution
that it's easier to go through the ipo
the traditional going public process
than dealing with digitizing and
digitized tokenized securities given
that the traditional process there's a
clear road map this less
of a risk this less of a gray area it
comes with a lot of hurdles
but it's exactly what you know they are
what they are everyone has people have
done it before
and yes it is a way to provide you know
public access
that said there are still limitations to
the traditional model
in that once and if coinbase is listed
on nasdaq
it's not easy at all for a chinese
resident and ecuadorian resident
peruvian vietnamese to participate they
those people cannot easily buy tesla
today
and they will not be easily uh have
access to to
coinbase in the future i think down the
road
i think it will take probably at least
five years
for the traditional public market to be
digitized and modified by what we will
see
in the sto world but over the next year
or two
the the change in in stose and digital
securities
for early stage companies and projects i
think will
pose a serious or at least raise the
serious conversations
for the nasdaq of the world because they
know that in five
years out they won't have candidates to
go ipo
given that people would already have
opted for digital uh
offerings uh much sooner
and so it sounds like it's fair to say
that people can go from
traditional non-digitized equity
and digitized at any point right in the
kind of life cycle of the business
but it's much harder if you start out
with digitized equity and kind of this
token structure
to go back to the traditional world
right so at some point once you cross
over it's hard to go back and
and say if i raise money early on
through a digital token structure
as equity to then go get listed on the
nasdaq or the nysc
would be pretty difficult well it is
rather than difficult i would say it's
a no and within that kind of highly
regulated world
any unknown poses a risk so i would say
that it's rather than it being difficult
as long as in your structuring of your
digital offering
uh you you know your sdo early on as a
private company
build in there a framework that is good
for investor
good for token holders but gives you the
ability that if you so choose it becomes
so
crucial for the company to go public
traditionally
that you have a way to give return back
to note holders and basically be able to
crawl back those tokens
in a way that that you know token
holders are happy with
and you know random shares in return so
there's still ways for you to go
you know to reverse and undo things uh
at least
you know we do see a path for that uh
but that is a big unknown and a
you know a question in my mind is
whether or not
the ipo model will continue to exist
five years out 2025 and above
and and beyond i don't know that you
will see the kind of like
you know uber and coinbase uh ipo that
we
that we are seeing now and we already
see
in the traditional world there's
definitely some movement or change right
so we've seen the
um you know spotifys and the slacks do
direct listings we've seen the virgin
galactics go through
uh these kind of spac acquisitions um
and so there's definitely some pressure
there or some
change it feels like digital security is
is kind of further out than just a one
or two-year
thing but to your point um if it can
solve some of these problems there's a
lot of companies that say why wouldn't i
do that if uh
if it's just a better path and not only
that truly the spac
and the the the ipo process is only
for the coinbase of the wharf uh and
even then
compared to the 90s the number of
companies you know the number of public
companies out there in the us
i think something like 50 less than it
was like 30 years ago so it
it has been a trend that's like less and
less
you know companies choose to go public
the notion of digital securities and
stos
uh is such that it's usable applicable
to even
seed stage uh companies and projects
uh so i do think that currently in the
near term
the two models serve very two different
demographics
coinbase is probably the only company
that i imagine that there was ever a
board conversation
of should we tokenize out our equities
and and make it available that way or
should we go public
and they seemingly chose to go public
but for pretty much everyone else that's
not a dilemma that they have to deal
with i
i don't think yeah it's absolutely
fascinating too to kind of hear like
what is your
pitch to entrepreneurs as to why should
they do this
especially the earliest stages of the
business rather than just race through
the traditional means
um the the the easiest way to think of
it is just i mean republic is
an example why do i answer that question
uh in the context of why
we decided to issue a digital securities
we are a fundraising platform
and the reason why we ended up you know
choosing to launch
as a crowdfunding or crowd investing
platform is that we think that
if a customer consumer community member
has skin in the game he or she would be
that much more
you know arden in in eventualizing and
buying more product and telling people
about it and that value
proposition is played through and
through uh there's no
clearer example of community community
ownership
than the fact that airbnb and uber
before they won ipo
asked the sec permission to give equity
to the drivers and the people you know
the
the lister and airbnb at the time the
sec said no no special exemption if you
want to do it you use
basic standard uh regulatory framework
so the value proposition of community um
ownership is very much there
in our case there are two routes one is
that we can
run another crowdfunding campaign for
the republic ourselves
and bring in 10 000 of our community
members each of whom
hold a pdf or save or prefer
share in republic the second option is
figuring out
a additional security to make it
available if
i were to have done or conduct a crowd
offering
for republic it works for those who get
in right away
but it doesn't allow them to transfer
these things easily
it doesn't allow me to make a
distribution of
two dollars per share per token back out
if someone holds
free shares how what am i going to wire
do an ach
you know payment so the the automation
behind payment settlement uh
transferability kyc aml and
international transactions
none of that would be possible with a
traditional
crowd investment campaign so that's why
we opted for it
and we have seen even just in the the
past few days
uh and the months leading up to it the
engagement
that a token model can can drive and how
it incentivized
people to be more active is undeniable
and we believe that that's that value
proposition
is applicable to pretty much any
business model with a community may be a
sports league
or a new project or a digital exchange
based out of
you know somalia whether maybe if you
have a community
digital tokenization and a token model
can apply to amplify it yeah it's really
interesting i guess too
because what you guys have seen is
you've basically brought this to some of
the most innovative types of companies
in the world right
we know that uh unaccredited investors
have a very hard time investing in
startups rent and technology companies
uh this very much of an insider's game
um and so it feels like this is one way
to kind of break down some of those
walls or democratize access to some
degree
how have uh entrepreneurs responded to
the fact that
now they've got a whole bunch of uh
equity holders or kind of new partners
and those people may have access to
certain types of information that's
considered sensitive or confidential
how does that play into this that that's
a great question
and i want to clarify one thing is that
the
no holders have indirect access to these
companies but we only provide
information that is public information
we would never provide information that
the company
hasn't released publicly for a couple of
reasons deference to them is one thing
they also may be inaccurate if i hear
that the company might have done
something and i
saying that oh geez company access about
to get acquired and
turns out that they didn't or aren't
that's going to be a major problem so we
only provide
you know thorough but public information
only
the at the level of a crowd investing or
crowdfunding campaign for a company like
republic
to take on a thousand new investors
we have to go through a pretty creative
legal process to make sure that that's
manageable
but one example at how manageable
that is is the fact that republic now
through the republic note sale
now have more than 6 000 new investors
coming
in and counting so if we can make it
manageable
you can trust that that that we you know
make available that same process to the
companies going out on our platform
but it's a little bit too uh boring and
archaic
of a legal uh deep dive on on how
exactly that is achieved
i'm more than happy to go in though if
anyone is curious
and obviously all of this has occurred
during a global pandemic that has led to
a recession but
seeing stock prices explode and we just
live in this like really weird complex
uh kind of uncertain time how have you
seen covet 19 and all of the
the kind of impact of that affect
fundraising for companies or even
companies wanting to go and use the
platform
first i want to share that even
fundraising during the pandemic
i'm sure is not as challenging
as planning for a wedding during a
pandemic and so on that note just wanna
say congratulations
again um the uh
the past six months have been obviously
an uncertain
a surreal time for all of us i do think
that
companies looking to raise from venture
raising venture capital of traditional
institutional capital
have been uh going through a hard time
meaning the public stock market has been
performing better
than anyone had expected perhaps
irrationally so
but that doesn't mean that that
institutional investors looking at
private capital
haven't slowed down a lot and you know
you may
uh you may be a far more experienced uh
you know person than than i am to share
a view on it but from my lens
i think a function of that is given the
volatility
in the public market a lot of family
offices uh and institutional investors
are delaying and and are much more
cautious about
investing and providing more exposure to
the private market right so
the process at the very least has been
dragged out
longer for founders and projects looking
to raise
a traditional venture capital
institutional capital on the other side
though
retail capital has been doing very well
like we
april was our best month yet then may
was much better than april
and june was like abandoned month for us
and it's the same
for other players in the market it's not
a story that's unique to a public
there's one clear solution there's one
clear answer
one is that people have a lot more time
now so the value of like private
investing
and quite frankly of blockchain as a
technology in general
most people open to now have too little
attention span like nine seconds online
like
by the time you finish saying equity
crowdfunding or
you know staff you know simple agreement
for future tokens people lost
interest now they're stuck at home so
they're like we're
you know between webinars and podcast
newsletter and all of these things that
they have
more uh attention to follow and i think
the
value proposition of of private
investing which is obvious
uh there's one interesting stat i think
it's from the
boston consulting group that in the year
2020
2030 10 years from now 75 percent of
fortune 500 companies in the year 2030
have yet to exist today so
you're talking about a huge swath
of technologies and household brands who
change how we work and
and live and yet in some someone's
garage or in someone's head today
the notion that you can put you know
ten dollars twenty dollars a picture of
beer worth
in some or more of these potential ideas
and play a role
in it i think it's naturally compelling
i don't think that anyone should be
expecting to get rich
out of private investing because they're
here in the news
it's just a wrong way of looking at it
but it's a really
compelling thing to say that you got to
be a bit more
of a direct participant in
entrepreneurship
given that it's changing how we are as a
civilization
so i think that the message finally is
getting through and because of that
retail capital
has and i predict will continue to do
very well
probably at one time larger than
institutional capital
yeah it's it's crazy to see the impact
and how
institutions kind of froze up and retail
uh invested a bunch and
um in the public markets obviously that
was very beneficial for retail investors
because stocks exploded
kind of with all the feds yet reaction
in the private market it's a little less
obvious right in terms of our companies
doing better or worse just because that
there's not kind of a daily stock price
to uh
to associate it with um help me
understand like we're
going to add on another point there is
that after the
last uh great recession of 2008
that's when you started to see i think
airbnb
launched in 2009 wasab strike
square like major companies
corporations now launch right after
following the recession so that's the
value of private investing is that it's
not
as affected by by near-term psychology
and volatility
and it only time will tell and i do
think
you're gonna see a similar batch of
household brands coming out of
today's pandemic yeah help me understand
where we're going
right digital securities uh you guys
have obviously helped pioneer this
you're able to show that there is a
community of investors you're able to
show that there is
a community of entrepreneurs that want
to use this as a way to
get funding for their businesses and
kind of continue to build
how does this evolve over time and where
do you see this going kind of over the
next five to ten years
uh and then what are the obstacles in
the way from where we are today to kind
of that milestone
uh two answers for for that and that's a
uh that's a hard question
it's forward-looking and i was wrong
about how quickly
sdo would be adopted back in you know
2017
but i'm very optimistic that you're
gonna see that in the next 12
at the latest 24 months and and seeing
what
if that's the question i think the
easiest way of looking
at a or the signal of
maturation in this space is when you
have like the spiderman the x-men
movie franchise or something comparable
in sports
with clearly many millions of fans
around the world
and when they're looking to race to
finance the movie
or the athlete and make it
through the only way to do that still
and will be in the near future
through this blockchain technology make
it possible
so that you know a student in india
can invest five bucks two dollars
into this movie to be produced because
you know she loves the
the the people and there's a
non-fungible token on her phone
that shows that hey she's you know an
investor in this new superman movie
and that if she goes back to her school
and can
sell it to her classmate you know very
quickly
for 10 more and the token would come
with it
and that's a new mark of being an
engaged citizen just like the equivalent
of like wearing a chanel bag
like what do you get in on and what what
do you own just a little sliver of it
that happening at scale i very much hope
to see that in
12 months no later than like 18 24
months
now once that's doable and once you see
something like that happening
um the the iteration
of tokenization naturally will come
it's very hard to predict the full scale
of it because i
fundamentally i mean i believe that this
technology will fundamentally change
private investing or private asset
classes as we know of it
first is people getting in at the
primary level
and then the secondary market will
develop that will naturally
unlock you know the the gold bars that
people have in africa and latin america
in asia
that up until now they're high under
their bed that's the only way that's the
best way to to
save because they don't believe in the
national currency and they
don't believe in the banking system once
you unlock all of that
i i yeah i do see a vastly more
prosperous war
and that perhaps we i don't know we may
not see another recession again
uh that will really throw traditional
economics um
you know completely off its rail the
challenge
uh is and will be how
fast and how aggressive regulatory
framework can adapt
or hinder this process d5 is a very good
example
so the you see i mean something like
over two or three billion
dollars worth of assets now locked in
various efi
uh instruments still largely
unregulated and so people take these
various positions and whether or not
it's even
regulatable given that it's a direct
transaction between
you know two parties uh that said you
know you have yield
in double digits i think some instrument
you over 100
you know annually it's bound to be you
know frauds and
harms and all of these things so the sec
and finra
and their equivalents in various country
uh i think will come in
and will will operate will collaborate
and will hinder
and how that conversation
or these conversations will take place
in each country i think
um basically is the one
single factor that will uh
enable one to predict how accurately
more accurately how fast a house loads
industry will be true uh but that's
something that's why
you know i very much believe in the
conversation with the legislator and
regulators
rather than ignoring
absolutely and then maybe talk a little
bit about the international nature here
right and kind of how this opens up
accessibility you hinted at a little bit
with the dpi stuff let me just touch on
that
the in the case of uh finance uh it's a
straight up up until now it's not a
globalized world it is a national
world that's why tesla if you're in
vietnam or ecuador you can't really buy
a public share of tesla it's crazy but
you cannot
uh and so these you know territorial or
national borders
a function of it is that up until now
these governments are unable to stop you
know the
the cross-border transactions and so
over time with so much activities going
going on that they have to find a way to
legitimize it and so
a function of it is driven by technology
and a function of it is going to be
driven
straight up by conversation and that in
smaller countries
seeing how this technology can improve
lives of people
in their country allowing them to invest
in things that are not
organically available locally but
available you know on a global scale
that i do think that that these borders
uh lying will get blurrier and blurrier
over time
when it comes to financing particularly
you know private investing which is
what d5 is by definition just truly
decentralized
yeah what's next for you what what do
you think at a republic in terms of
what are the things you guys are focused
on over the next kind of six to 12
months
yes uh after we're done with our public
sale
and we even though we oversubscribed now
we're gonna i think open a small
application just to make our community
happy
uh and after that is focusing on a few
more things which is
uh you know qualifying our rec a
application
to make sure that we formalize the
process of getting non-accredited
investors in
after that is really around community
engagement the whole process of making
sure that we provide
information for for the new voters but
beyond that
i would say the next 12 months using the
framework that we applied that we
created and now apply
for the node token for other businesses
we're really working with a few
so you hope to you know we hope you will
see
more uh digital securities
issued by major enterprises with
very clear value propositions and a
massive community
you know issuing tokens to those
communities in the same way the republic
is doing to our own community and so
the my my interest and effort i think
focus squarely
probably 100 just on the notion of
making tokenization uh
you know hopefully mainstream at last uh
still a little bit of way to go but
we think it's there i love it man
you uh you continue to push the pace of
innovation so it's
it's impressive to watch um i've been uh
super excited about what you guys are
doing and uh
obviously the republic note token i
think will uh will go down
as many people will say hey that's a
pretty good idea and they will
end up copying that type of mechanism so
congratulations on all the success where
can we send people to learn more about
you
or republic first of all thank you so
much paul
coming from you it really you know means
the world you've seen everything in this
space
and and uh advice and guidance over the
years has been
so crucial for us uh yeah we're at
republic.co.com
pretty much the entire uh white paper
and all relevant information
can be found on that site and i do want
to clarify that as
all things related to private investing
high risk don't invest money that you
you know that you don't expect or can't
afford to lose in its entirety
uh and if you do invest in something new
like invest a very small amount
like think of it it's like having fun
with it and make sure that you read
everything
uh that that is available uh to to make
that uh informed decision but
uh i hope you uh jump in and have some
fun
absolutely so republic.co slash note
please guys go check it out if you think
it's something that you may be
interested in
uh and then kendrick thank you so much
for doing this man i'm super excited and
uh
i'm glad that we got caught up in terms
of just where digital securities are
today
and uh hopefully the the path that you
laid out uh moving forward not only one
uh kind of occurs but happens even
faster than you think it will which
would which would be fantastic for uh
for innovation in the finance industry
so
fingers crossed and i'm cheering you
guys on thank you so much sir